here is a tweet from Dr Peter Hotes this
is what sparked the entire thing
Spotify has stopped even sort of trying
to stem Joe Rogan's vaccine
misinformation it's really true Adam
Merlin just awful and from all the
online attacks I'm receiving after this
absurd podcast it's clear many actually
believe this nonsense now the the Absurd
podcast he's referring to of course is
RFK on Rogan now remember he's also
claiming that Rogan is spreading
misinformation on Spotify but he had no
problem going on Rogan's show to say
whatever it is that he wanted to say so
anyway now we're going to go into a
whole bunch of tweets here Rogan then
responded to that
and and this is really where the thing
caught fire he said Peter if you claim
what RFK Jr is saying is misinformation
I am offering you a hundred thousand
dollars to the charity of your choice if
you're willing to debate him on my show
with no time limit Hotes then responded
to that Joe you have my cell my email
and I'm always willing to speak to you
then Rogan responded this is a
non-answer I challenged you publicly
because you publicly quote tweeted and
agreed with that dog Vice article
if you're really serious about what you
stand for you now have a massive
opportunity for a debate that will reach
the largest audience a discussion like
this has ever had if you think someone
else is better qualified please suggest
that person so you can see this thing
was starting to percolate then Elon Musk
got involved and this is where it
started sort of breaking into a new uh
level Elon then responded to Joe and
said he's afraid of public debate
because he knows he's wrong then Peter
hotez responded to Rogan Joe if you are
serious about addressing vaccines and
the fact that 200 000 unvaccinated
Americans needlessly perished during our
awful delta ba1 covid waves including 40
000 in our state of Texas because they
fell victims to vaccine disinformation I
want to have that discussion then Rogan
responded again I'm going to ask you
very clearly are you willing to debate
Robert Kennedy Jr on my podcast then
this guy Tom Nichols who's a staffer at
the Atlantic I think he's occasionally
on MSNBC he responded with this and you
can now start to see how the lines were
being drawn on what side people are on
uh he said no medical professional
should ever agree to do this never it
elevates the conspiracy guide demeans
the medical professional and will only
convince the Kooks out there that Jay
that RFK is right because a real doctor
took the time to debate him never debate
a conspiracy theorist oh
Rogan saw that and Rogan said that would
be a great suggestion if you could
assure that the industry you were
representing wasn't completely captured
by heartless monsters who have a history
of some of the biggest criminal fines in
human history because their deceptions
has cost hundreds of thousands of people
their lives it would be a great
suggestion if the industry you were
defending didn't occasionally look at
human's beat didn't occasionally look at
human beings as an opportunity to
generate insane wealth regardless of the
tragic consequences but you can't do
that so maybe it would be a good idea to
have a debate okay so now you
can sort of see what's going on here
we're going to do a little more in just
a sec but you can see what's going on
here Rogan is basically saying hey
hotels you're basically calling for me
to be banned from Spotify even though
I've had you on my show to present your
side and then I had RFK on my show to
present the other side so let's just
let's just debate and then you can see a
whole bunch of people because this Tom
Nichols guy wasn't the only one a whole
bunch of people Maddie Hassan from MSNBC
and others basically like no you don't
debate conspiracy theorists and this is
what they've done with everybody right
they label you a conspiracy theorist or
you're a racist or a bigot or a
homophobic transphobed so that they
don't have to debate you right that's
basically how everything has operated